just over an hour ago and 1500 miles
away the world was implored to listen
and watch red square
this is the victory parade in honour of
the 77th anniversary of the victory in
the great patriotic war
but really what president putin wants is
the russian people in the world to be
awed and intimidated by the ongoing
memorial to militarism
and i believe that his ongoing and
unprovoked conflict in ukraine does
nothing but dishonor those same soldiers
both the ones marching across red
squares i speak and all the forebearers
they supposedly march to commemorate
let me be clear
it's right to honour the sacrifice of
those many many millions who contributed
to europe europe's liberation from
fascism and the nazi reign of terror
it was a period of immeasurable
destruction atrocities and human
suffering particularly in eastern europe
and the former soviet union including
ukraine
there will be no mention today in moscow
however but much of the suffering was
self-inflicted by stalin and his
generals
while in moscow in february i accepted
the honor of laying a wreath at the tomb
of the unknown soldier beneath the vast
red walls of the kremlin itself
it stands in memory of those russians
who lost their lives fighting the
invading nazis as the inscription
proclaims the names are unknown but
their deeds are immortal
as i stood in front of the honor guard
themselves so young with such uncertain
fates even those few weeks later my
thoughts were for the ordinary russian
soldiers so many of them conscripts who
found themselves in a battle for
personal and national survival against
the nazi regime
i thought about the scale of the
suffering across the soviet union
but also how the suffering was used then
as it is now to cover up the inadequacy
of those ruling in safety and comfort
from behind the kremlin walls above and
within the general staff nearby
most soviet conscripts hadn't a chance
their suffering was often needless
in the absence of effective military
leadership many of their best officers
were purged by the nkvd for
counter-revolutionary crimes
while barrier troops executed swathes
retreating soldiers deemed unpatriotic
for failing to press on in the face of
unassailable odds
fear and sycophancy dictated behaviors
then
and today's russian armed forces still
carry that soviet imprint the imprint of
immorality and corruption
through the invasion of ukraine putin
his inner circle and his generals are
now mirroring fascism and tyranny of 77
years ago
repeating the errors of the last
century's totalitarian regimes
they are showing the same disregard for
human lives national sovereignty and the
rules-based international system
the very system not least the united
nations charter itself that we conceive
together and for which we fought and
were victorious together in the hope of
saving future generations from the
scourge of war
their unprovoked illegal senseless and
self-defeating invasion of ukraine their
attacks against innocent civilians and
their homes their widespread atrocities
including the deliberate targeting of
women and children
they are all corrupt the memory of past
sacrifices and russia's once proud
global reputation
the response to this failure by the
russian forces on the ground in ukraine
has in itself been disgraceful display
of self-preservation doubling down on
failure anger dishonesty and
scapegoating
the behavior of the russian general
staff has shown that their own
self-preservation comes first
war crimes targeting civilians and the
casualty rates in their own battalion
tactical groups are all secondary
concerns
the truth is
that russia's general staff are failing
and they know it
while i'm angry at the behavior of their
army and do not in any way remove
culpability from the ordinary soldier
for what horrors they are inflicting
i'm equally angry at the general staff's
absence of integrity
and leadership that should go up as well
as down
and should be expected of all
professional military officers
all professional soldiers should be
appalled at behavior of the russian army
not only are they engaged in illegal
invasion and war crimes but their top
brass have failed their own rank and
foul to the extent they should face
court martial